hey guys it's Eric Happy New Year it's
January 1st 2019 this is a time of year
where it's hard to like actually write
the date correctly so inclined to write
2018 but okay hopefully everyone had a
good start to the year I'm currently in
a small village where the Wi-Fi is a
little bit sub-optimal hence why I'm not
streaming but I figured I would try to
record some some video for YouTube and I
just got a comment it was 35 minutes ago
let me see if I can show this to the
screen hey Eric great videos as always
could you do a tutorial explaining the
basics basic variations of the
Budapest's really love your comments
content from hugo go boards okay so hugo
go Boortz you asked a question at the
right time because we're gonna look at
some basic variations of the budapest
gambits an opening which i've played so
many times on stream probably one of the
most aggressive openings against e4 and
it starts after d4 if I can access
aboard d4 Knight f6 e4 and the next move
from lock which is pawn on e5 is a start
of the Budapest okay there's some lag
let me try that again
Pawnee 5 and the point of the opening is
to okay first we'll get your opponent
out of their comfort zone if they're a
d4 player and I mean this assume that
most people who are watching this are
around like amateur level like below mm
probably somewhere between a thousand to
2,000
so most d4 players in that rating range
are having more solid tendency don't
necessarily like to be attacked so
quickly and the Budapest gambit aims to
initiative really quickly for black at
the expense of a pond now most of the
times white will take looks like a free
pond it looks like a great deal too
because white takes upon and attacks a
knight on f6 and I remember when I first
saw that this existed as an opening I
just I didn't want to go further it just
it looks completely nonsensical to give
away a pawn and then move the same piece
twice but then the first person who
showed it to me took a very good
approach because they showed like the
the most kind of natural looking line
where black ends up winning before move
ten and by winning I mean check meaning
so I just want to show like just a
natural looking variation starting with
Knight g4 normal move attacking the pawn
just wanting to to recapture next and in
many cases if black can regain the pawn
then the the resulting development won't
be too difficult like black can normally
develop pretty harmoniously if if a pawn
is one so normally white will try and
hold on to the pawn let's say Bishop f4
black can play knight c6 attacking the
pawn even further most natural move for
whites it's nine of three and now there
are two attackers and two defenders so
black can't win the pawn right away but
there is a nice follow-up here for black
Bishop to b4 check developing and
gaining time forcing white to somehow
block the check and also preparing
queenie 7 it's important to develop the
bishop first and then play queen e7
later so that the Queen isn't blocking
the Bishop from f8 so White's most
common move here is Knight B to d2 and
now this is where black can play Queen
e7 and now we see that there are three
attackers on the pawn queen and both
nights there are only two defenders and
there's actually no good way for white
to defend the pawn and black is just
to win upon here now a lot of players is
white will play a three attempting to
counter-attack attacking the bishop
maybe trying to grab the bishop hair and
from this position it may seem like
black has to move the bishop but black
actually has another option which is not
a Bishan move and the move to play for
black is simply taking the pawn Knight
takes e5 you can actually take with
ether Knights
let's say Mike D G takes e5 and this was
a very first variation I was shown and
at first it was a little confusing like
why not
white just just take the free bishop on
b4 but then if you look closer
turns out black has an immediate win if
you don't see it pause the video black
to move checkmate in one move i t3 is
check and mate smothered mates very nice
that the Queen aligns with the King
pinning the e to pawn and there's no
escape for whites now I've shown this to
students and usually when I show this to
students I tell them if they get to this
position and their opponent plays a
three
you should very quickly take on e5 there
should be really no no hesitation
especially if it's online if it's online
blitz or bullets like just get ready to
take on e5 because a lot of players will
assume that that you just didn't realize
that Bishop was attacked and they'll
gladly take it without thinking twice
and then you make them so of course
whites I cannot take the bishop the
bishop is so-called poisonous on b4
after Knight takes e5 another common
line here is Knight takes e5 and then
black can just take back lock and take
leave the bishop hanging if the bishop
is still taken then there's 93 mate
still and if white takes on e5 again
this is where it's important to be
accurate because you can't get
way with just taking on e5 because then
you lose your Bishop and you're you're
down a piece so it's important to play
an intermediate move first take the
knight on d2 with check and we Ches
disconnected there but now it's
reconnected and okay after Queen takes
on d2 Queen takes e5 and that was all
just one big trade if we evaluate the
position blacks at least equal maybe
slightly preferable because the queen is
just very nicely placed in the center
black Castle played d6 and complete
development without without any real
issues so so yeah once I learned this
one line that was enough to start
playing the Budapest because this is uh
okay I'm not gonna say that white will
get mated most of the time but white
will usually go into some position like
this most of the time or black will will
usually win the pawn back and best-case
scenario mate white and how many means
it takes b4 of a 19-3 mate this was
eight moose just out of curiosity I want
to show just the the Lee chest opening
explorer here let's switch the view and
if you're in a leech s study you can see
how many times a certain position has
occurred people are challenging me in
which I'm going to decline for now she
it was just one person but okay so let's
go back to to this position after a
three let's look up the position I'm
using the the Lee chess database and
it's a little bit slow because the
internet connection but bear with me
here we go Knight G takes e5 played
almost 5000 games how many players took
on b4 oh man over a thousand players
took on d4 and then ninety three mates
is not the only move some people played
Knight takes f3
that's got to be so unfortunate like
getting to this position having made in
one and then taking on f3
now fortunately for most people neither
93
the most common move at least fortunate
for the black players and okay a
thousand games ended like this and then
of course there's this other line where
black black takes with the sea Knight
also very playable I think most of the
time this line could transpose it takes
b4 and then 93 mates again a few people
don't know what they're doing but my t3
finishes a game so yeah well over a
thousand people have gotten mated before
of ten as white against the Budapest so
going back here it's an opening at least
it's an opening trap that's very easy to
learn and there's not too much
memorization that's required
you remember E 5 the rest of the moves
are very normal I just keep attacking
the pawn attack the pawn with the
Knights give a check play queenie 7
defend the pawn and then get to this
position and set up the trap now the
commenter on youtube was asking i think
for some basic variations oh he was
saying can you do a tutorial explaining
the basics
ok basic variations of the budapest
maybe I'll give one more variation which
is completely different but also just a
nice trap let's go back to the position
after E 5 because there are some white
players who are just scared of accepting
gambits and will decline gambits at all
costs and there's a move that I've run
into a good deal online which is just
not a good move for light which is pawn
d5 and this is not a tactical mistake
but it's more of a positional mistake
like why it's overextending not
developing any minor pieces and
especially after d5 this gives away the
c5 square for the
the black bishop and black can play
Bishop to c5 immediately and already
it's very pleasant I mean black is ready
to Castle next move and white has
nothing developed and black can usually
continue the setup upon d6
sometimes pawn c6 - try and undermine
white structure very often rook e8 will
be played and in many of my games I like
to play Knights be d7 to f8 to g6 and
then later in the middle game get a King
side attack but in the specific position
I want to show just one nice trap which
can emerge after Bishop to g5 which
looks like a nice move on the surface
like pins and mites develops a piece
unfortunately for a white this is just a
terrible blunder and it just walks into
a simple tactic and if you don't see it
feel free to pause the video and find
the material winning move for black in
this position and I'm giving more time
than normal because Lee chess is
reconnecting where people can see this
reconnecting so we're no waits until
it's reconnected okay it's reconnected
so the move is actually there might be a
few good moves for black but just the
easiest move to play as Bishop takes f2
white is obliged to take and then Bach
has a choice after King takes f2 of
either Knights g4 or Nighy for I'm
pretty sure people can visualize this as
Lee chess continues to try and reconnect
but okay after actually after King takes
F - I think Knight e4 is the best option
and then black will very easily regain
the bishop with Queen takes g5 and just
be up upon with great position white
will have lost castling rights just to
show this on the board
oh no what's going on everything's blue
oh it flipped you want to have the
person
to the winning side kingi one let's say
and queen takes g5 okay
I'm clearly having some lag issues if
people want to see this trap you can
watch my previous video I had a very
similar trap in one game which I
actually almost managed to lose is black
but then I won it was like very
topsy-turvy in nature anyway I think I'm
gonna end it there because of the issues
and also just because I wanted to keep
this simple and just show some some
inspirational variations to get to get
people started who maybe had no
knowledge on the Budapest before
watching this video so if you guys want
to see more videos on the Budapest or if
there's any recommendations in terms of
any sort of little things you want to
learn leave a comment below I'm gonna
try and do more more like viewer
requests in terms of doing opening
tutorials and answering questions so let
me know your feedback and I'll see you
guys in the next video